How long can you stay underwater?
It might depend on the size of your .... wait
for it...spleen.
Recent studies have revealed human adaptation
to the high altitudes of the Andes and Himalayas.
These adaptations involve the ability of blood
to carry or hold oxygen in these low-oxygen
heights.
Now researchers are looking for adaptations
in people who spend a lot of time under water.
The Bajau people --also known as “Sea Nomads”--
have spent thousands of years diving deep
underwater without tanks or snorkels.
Bajau divers may spend as much as 60 percent
of their workday under the surface, spearing
fish and harvesting sea cucumbers.
mammals, including people have something called
a “dive reflex” -- which is triggered
when you plunge your face into the water.
Once submerged, your heart rate slows.
Vessels in your extremities constrict-
shunting blood to the body’s core.
And your spleen gets a big squeeze.
This spleen squeeze pumps
oxygen-rich red blood cells into the bloodstream.
And the researchers in this study found that
the Bajau have spleens that are 50 percent
larger than their land-based neighbors.
It’s possible that these larger spleens
may serve as a reservoir for extra oxygenated
blood needed for long breathless dives.
The researchers then looked to see
if there was a genetic component
they wanted to know if big spleens are inherited
or if something else was going on.
After comparing the Bajou DNA with DNA from
nearby farmers and from Han Chinese, the team
found 25 genes that were different in the Bajou.
One notable difference was in a gene called PDE10A.
Other researchers had found that in mice,
this gene can affect thyroid activity, which
in turn affects spleen size.
While it is unlikely one gene is responsible
for the size of the spleen, the research strongly
suggests that there is a genetic component
to this spleen enlargement.
And it shows whether it’s high-altitude living
or deep-diving life,
humans have adapted to low-oxygen environments
in a number of different ways throughout history
I can’t wait to see what we do in space.